[موسيقى]
رئيس الليغا يكشف اقتراح الابقاء ميسي
رفضه لا بورتا رخصه القبه لم تقعد تشوف
واستدعاء جودزي مع المانيا الكثيرين هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
كشف رئيس الليجا خافييرتي باز عن عرض قدمه
لبرشلونه للالقاء على ميسي العام الماضي
لكنه قبل بالرفض وقالت في كتابه بانه عرض
على برشلونه وانديه اسبانيا الانضمام الى
مشروعا كبيره لفرقه الدرجه الاولى لكن
فكره المشروع والنتيجه كانت رحله ميسي الى
نادي سان جيرمان
بول بوغبا نجمه يوفنتوس المصاب حاول اقناع
مدرب المنتخب الفرنسي بضمه لكن على طريقته
الخاصه بوجبا نشر الفيديو على الانستغرام
وهو يرقص في منزله وكتب قائلا افضل طريقه
لاختبار الركبه محاوله بوجبا لم تجد نفعا
بعد ما اعلنتيشن النهائي المشاركه في كاس
العالم والتي شهدت غياب اللاعب الفرنسي
من جاءته فجاه مدرب المنتخب البلجيكي
روبرتو مارتينيز المتابعين بعد استدعائه
لمهاجم
رغم الاصابه التي يعاني منها
منذ طلاق موسم لكن ورغم هذا يبدو مارتن
للحرس القديم حيث ضم ايضا هازار الذي
ابتعد عن مستواه ولم يعد هو اللاعب ذات
الذي شارك في مونديال روسيا قبل اربع
سنوات
الاختيارات المفاجئه لم تتوقف عند بلجيكا
بعدما استدعى مدرب المانيا هاز فليك لاعب
فرانكفورد ماريو جودزيت عادي يعني المنتخب
الاكثر من خمس سنوات رواد السوشيال ميديا
ابدو استغرابهم من هذا القرار لكن البعد
قال بان الصداع جودزي قد يجلب الحظ الجيد
للمنتخب بعد التسجيل هدف الفوز الذي اهدى
المانيا مرحبا الرابع في كاس العالم عام
[موسيقى]